every friday we will be doing something
we're calling
the weekender
[Music]
so this is just a little helpful guide
we put together as a part of drew's news
where we share
our picks on what to watch a read a
follow
ado and a listen to over the weekend
so welcome to our first of many
weekenders
all right that's a shot okay first
you have to watch the new paris hilton
youtube doc
this is paris i was glued to my screen
here's a look just created this brand
and this persona
and this character and
i've been stuck with her ever since
is that enough no
i mean i would have watched this on mere
curiosity but what i ended up getting
out of it was much more than i expected
so
paris will actually be here on the show
on monday and we're definitely going to
talk about
all of this and ask her a lot of
questions i have so many
okay next step i couldn't put this book
down yeah i'm reading it right now
and you can too it's called untamed by
glennon doyle
it's a cross between a memoir and a call
to action
that is so inspirational it will make
you look at how you're living your own
life in a totally different way
people are freaking out over this book
there are
all sorts of glowing reviews on the book
itself and here's one of my very
favorite
robert says goodbye again very
interesting
don't let your wife get a hold of it
you'll know why if you read it
i love it moving on you've got to check
out this podcast
it's called 365 days with mxm
tune every day for the next year
the 20 year old singer songwriter who
created this podcast spotlights
weird history and pop culture events
that happen on
this same day of the year but in another
year
this weekend she's got an episode on
emojis and simon and garfunkel
and another on billie jean king and the
bridle's breaking up
she's cool she's curious and i totally
dig it
i know next click that follow button
for the young emperors on instagram
they're a french influencer couple who
take photography
and make it fashion and they take
fashion and make it performance art
and they always match in perfect
coordination which is the way they say
they show their love for one another
look at these
outfits i know it's so romantic i love
them and we actually have a little
blossoming
friendship on instagram so i would love
to say
young emperors will you please come on
the show
okay this next one is a little secret of
mine and a true treat for your taste
buds
okay one day years ago i was at this
restaurant and i had this amazing
cheesecake
big cheesecake fan and so i freaked out
and i was begging them to please tell me
the recipe or where did they get it and
they were like i don't know we think we
bought it so i was like
listen anything info apb on this
cheesecake
because i can't imagine the rest of my
life without it so finally they gave it
up
and told me that i could get one too and
now
you can as well because it's from sam's
club
look at this beauty by the way fun fact
i haven't actually had it since that day
and i've been dreaming about it so
here we go i want to see if it's as good
as i remember
ratio creamy gram like
perfection
[Music]
i'm sorry am i wasting everybody's time
here because i
can't i mean please okay i'm gonna stop
okay after the commercial break
sam's club i love you and finally if you
want to do something this weekend
shopping
without having to leave the house check
out the website rulala.com
they've got the best of designer
clothing accessories home beauty
everything at such good freaking prices
and guess what
we're teaming up with them and we're
launching drew lala
that's right every tuesday starting next
week we'll be sharing our favorite
products with you
and we're going to have some sweet deals
to get everyone pumped up about it
today's vffs virtual friends and family
you're each getting a 50 credit to rue
la la
yeah that's a way to go into the weekend
and that is the weekender
[Music]
you